Exploratory data analysis is an opportunity to let
the data surprise you. Think back to the
goals of your investigation. What question are you
trying to answer? That question might be relatively simple
or one dimensional like the comparison of two
groups on a single outcome variable that you
care about. Even in such a case, exploratory
data analysis is an opportunity to learn about surprises
in the data. Features of the data that
might lead to unexpected results. It can also be
an opportunity to learn about other interesting things
that are going on in your data. What should
you do first? While certainly you want to
understand the variables that are most central to your
analysis, often, this is going to take the form
of producing summaries and visualizations of those individual variables.